y la ley de promoción de la alimentación
no es saludable e impulsada por el
oficialismo fue cuestionada por la
industria alimenticia porque no les
conviene a los proveedores de alimentos
declarar sus ingredientes y porque
necesitamos como consumidores estar
enterados podría decirse que diariamente
somos víctimas de publicidades engañosas
sobre lo que comemos
buenas noches ángeles cómo estás en
realidad fue apoyada por el oficialismo
y también por la oposición de hecho toda
la regulación del etiquetado frontal
comenzó en la gestión que yo estuve como
ministro hasta hace dos años y que
culminó ahora con la aprobación
parlamentaria y efectivamente esto tiene
que ver con no solamente la defensa de
la salud pública y abordar un problema
tan tan tan actual como es la el
sobrepeso y la obesidad en argentina que
también es un problema en el resto de la
región particularmente la obesidad
infantil sino también implica el derecho
a la información a que el consumidor en
el punto de compra pueda tener acceso a
la información sobre aquellos productos
envasados que tienen exceso de
nutrientes críticos como el sodio las
grasas o los azúcares agregados mire la
ley prohíbe hacer publicidad comercial
que vaya dirigida a niños y adolescentes
con productos que tienen sellos de
advertencia esto es una forma de
proteger a los menores los medios están
plagados en américa latina' de
publicidades con productos azucarados
para los más pequeños
absolutamente el problema hoy del
sobrepeso la obesidad y la obesidad
infantil es un problema que afecta
particularmente a los jóvenes a los
chicos de hecho más del 50% de los
chicos tienen sobrepeso y obesidad en la
argentina- y claramente esto repercute
muchísimo en los entornos escolares por
supuesto los alimentos envasados que
tengan sellos negros no van a poder ser
vendidos ni esté entregados en las
escuelas por ejemplo como así tampoco en
los comederos o como así tampoco en los
planes alimentarios lo cual es una
avance porque hoy la obesidad
lamentablemente es un problema que se
concentra en los pobres el problema en
la argentina es mucho más que el hambre
que no es un problema es la malnutrición
y la malnutrición enex por exceso y no
solo el sobrepeso y la obesidad y los
niños que están mal nutridos y que
padecen de obesidad serán adultos que
tendrán problemas por ejemplo de riesgo
cardíaco así que esta es una cuestión
que va mucho más allá de la vida diaria
sino que es un tema de salud pública se
ahorrará dinero el sistema de salud
argentino o con ésta la ley
yo creo que digamos mirado a largo plazo
el desarrollo del capital humano está
directamente relacionado con la
educación y con la salud y claramente
estos chicos pierden oportunidades
educativas oportunidades laborales y por
supuesto el riesgo de enfermedades
crónicas y creo que la industria como ha
sucedido en chile en uruguay en perú en
mexico en muchos otros países que están
emprendiendo este camino realmente lo
que va a tener que hacer es modificar el
contenido de algunos productos que van a
tener sellos negros y reformular los lo
que se está haciendo en todos los países
que hoy tienen la etiqueta de
advertencia y creo que es una buena
señal para promover la alimentación
saludable por supuesto esto solo no
resuelve el problema del sobrepeso y la
obesidad relacionada con la pobreza pero
es un camino de avance de estos digamos
de este proceso